Let's go to the phones and see what is going on. Why don't we start with- at (617)-830-4750.
Let's start with Caesar from San Antonio. Caesar from San Antonio, go ahead.
Caesar: Uh, hello?
David: Yeah, that's you
Caesar:  I-I-I-I have a question I want to ask you.
David:  Yeah, go ahead.
Caesar: Um, y'know we are averaging more than one mass shooting every day now, and a lot of them seem to get worse.
I mean, do people feel so irate and-and stressed out about their lives and
That they need to shoot up their
workplace or school
Because I can't imagine a classmate or a co-worker for that matter
Just go one day wake up and say, "I'm killing everyone tomorrow and actually doing it?"
David: Well, I mean I think that...I-I
That that's the problem right that even though when we think of our own lives
Maybe some of us do know people where we would say, you know
I actually can think of a couple of people who might choose to solve problems or try to solve problems by shooting others
most of us would say I don't really know people who would do that and yet as you point out we're having
Dozens of shootings a day and minutes some of those are mass shootings a lot of them individual shootings
so the problem I think is a
Multi-faceted one people who say that the problem is only guns or wrong
but guns are part of the problem people who say that mental health is the only
Problem are very wrong because mental health with access to very lethal firearms are extraordinarily
problematic
but part of it is the cultural aspect of
When there are problems
thinking about using guns to try to solve them and that's something that is bigger than
Mental health and it's bigger than gun safety
Although those are important things and yeah, I mean - a lot of people think of doing exactly that Cesar
That's the problem too. Many people are saying I have a problem that I've identified. I have a grievance
I'm going to obtain or I already have firearms and I'm gonna do something with them
Because of what I'm feeling and that's what we need to change culturally
I'm like
What would you like would you do it feel like if you found out someone?
that you that you personally or close to you that that was gonna like
Kill people like I found out that they were planning on doing it or if I found out that they had done it
Like they were planning on doing it. It depends on the situation. But first I would assess try to assess for myself
Is this for real and if it is I would let the police know
I mean what what it would be immoral not to I would have to do that
It would be difficult if it's a close friend. Imagine if it's a family member
But I could not in any way
live with myself
Not doing something if I know someone is thinking about going out there and harming other people
Mhmmm, I remember I still remember like many years ago
I'm also um young enough to remember Columbine when that happened. Yeah, that was shocking
yeah, I mean it's
Unfortunately if if Columbine happened today
I think we would not be nearly as shocked like Michael Moore wouldn't do another
documentary a documentary about one shooting now would seem pointless because in the time that you're producing the documentary
There would probably be a handful more similar shootings and that I think that's that's a good point Caesar that points out
Just how bad it has gotten a Caesar appreciate the call. Thank you so much